and what a pass there by Riley Smith a lot of
interchanging on this ship watch this wow what
a goal this is the soccer pass he'll never score
a prettier goal than that so stall had to go off
je replaced him McKinnon with a DT move scor look
at McKinnon spinning on the wall watch the back
door right off the skate of Ryan Johansson and
that's a good goal all day long no kicking motion
you're allowed him to flex and what a sweet
play by Nathan mckinon thrown it on that bit
of a lucky break oh I say ran Johansson knew
exactly what he was doing so far this season
here's a gy maret off to a hot start dropping it
back off Riley Smith and front score what a pass
there by Riley Smith you give time and space
to malcin like that he's going to find another
play I actually thought he was going to cut to
the middle and rip this Puck instead he draws
a Defender hands it off to Riley Smith and you
talk about a beautiful backhand pass what a feed
by Riley Smith that combination so far this year
has been a real great spot for this t team as he
buys some time Puck comes in front chance for kzco
he scores what Patience by Andre kzco after the
fine work by Phil D JPI takes on three comes up
with the puck puts it out front kco Waits Waits
Bowski getting tangled up with his own teammate as
kusenko just outweighted them the captain in makes
a move in on goal C in to neighbors he scores
wow what big goal by the blues right there cber
capping him with an unbelievable effort beautiful
playmaking thinkig neighbors have been aactor on
that one there see the young man half be casy
C just dancing out here on Saturday night here
is Kyle Connor now moving around with the p up
top Kyle Connor takes a look hands it off to shy
F he gives it to morisy mory's passing from TI
lot of interchanging on this ship watch this C
around drop pass button hooked by con movement
Puck possession find your lane convert little
redirection right there just needs to elevate
Skinner goes down in tight shle elevates up top
and the Jets win this one in overtime dropped it
to COV spins away from nen Hopkins backhander up
front Harman score curl with a pass all the way
across to zuk Carell and that's exactly what I
thought I saw alive this is the soccer pass
the Norwegian kicks it with his skate right
onto the paint Ryan Hartman's had so many great
opportunities to score and he deposits that one
in the back of the net and that has to feel
good for that line he back in lar darting him
with the backand Johnny SC that was an absolute
thing of beauty just when you think you haven't
seen a kale marar highlight yet you haven't
loved he comes in and buries a backand top
shell fre under the bar from basically the face
off dot now look he's looking holds mik comes
out it throws off the Gap from the defenseman
and he goes backside Just sh watch we get him
bumping shots oh here we go B's got a man open
Evangelista with a new stick coming in Evangelista
score Evangelista broke the stick out another one
from Pete Rogers and he broke it in in a hurry
look at that fake pulls it back uses his Edge wide
open net for Luke Evangelista assist to babro and
give one to Pete Rogers he got a new stick and
then just deep black one right out of his shorts
mat cutting in to the p and score what a goal
terrific read of the situation by Mike Masson
he understood the overplay he took advantage
of it he went the other way split Sean ther
and John Marino right down the middle and
what a finish VCH vanich through the five
hole otter stumbles the skates of Carlson Center
circle otter back on on his
blaz with speed between the
legs Paul coner shows off the hands wow cter fakes
the shot between the legs you see as soon as he
fakes that shot it forses Z Moola to stand up
straight as he stands up straight it goes between
the legs with it puts it Far Side on heart and wow
is the only word he'll never score a prettier goal
than that for Norris back up high it's serson
settles it down play it up side of the M goes
move the puck move the bodies that's what you do
to have a successful power play and the Senators
move this Puck around quickly it's not on their
stick more than a split second whoever touches it
the Puck's moving and it makes the penalty Killers
have to continually adjust to the puck movement
and then all of a sudden the back door break their
doors I want to do too how long is the rebuild
going to take ainson in alone SC oh that's a spicy
dangle from Cam Atkinson good job by the Flyers
to break the puck out they've got great support
coming off the board we talk about that hockey IQ
ainson goes to a place where he knows the tipic
can get him the puck he goes in virtually all
alone but what a finish sweet hands it's been a
dominant effort by kado unbelievable wide open
net for Devon C Tic Tac Toe what a beauty caves
will make the pass and stay down low Ross Hold is
standing front of Peter morazzi morzac has no idea
where the pck is at this point Holden's done a
tremendous job screening NuSkin puts it perfectly
K almost misses it actually he goes into the far
Corner went buried in the right forsberg drives
through one wave of blue jerseys forsberg scores
I love this just stick with it he's just going to
overpower Sherk and he takes it all by himself he
goes up top he gets a little space he sees this
and this is confidence look at him all by himself
gets up he's go down on one knee he opens up he
freezes the penalty Killers they're backed off
and that allows him to walk in and just set up his
shot and just blows it by shur hustles to makes a
move behind the goal working on Mika centers
Pon Choi scores what a setup from Andre kzco
put on the tape of Alias Pon oh that was a sweee
from py for sureo is able to roll behind the net
and do a quick little fake like he's coming out
the other side and he does but the spin to elude
Nika and the rosi is down and this is going over
the glove last it walking in Jack rosic scores
the game winner heads up play by rosic he fakes
like he's going to change he actually looks at the
bench when he gets his Puck he fakes a drop back
pass and then he takes it up the middle of the
ice casually yeah yeah go ahead I'll drop it back
no here I go weaves his way in he's got everyone
trying to scatter to get towards him and then he
pops it home beautiful play by Jack rovic it's
neander centers Tara swivel back to nander scores
William nander and a great setup by tarz this
is just a great effort by John tarz kind of gets
turned over here loses the puck and just the quick
little spin around off the skate and then off the
side of the net William neander just staying with
it there getting the quick shot and what a start
to the season he is having B ahead Logan o Conor
turns on the jet can he do it again he scores what
a pass that was to H Logan o coner and he slides
in the back hand for three short-handed goals and
three straight games Logan o Conor is officially
on the heater just slipp that right under the
blocker he elevated that baby on the back end
got it underneath the blocker aleno back for fer
back to Valen scar Joe valeno set up beautifully
by Christian fiser you go in behind the net and
you go back the other way fer did and valeno there
the goal tender looking to his right when the
puck hits him in the back of the left leg and he's
nothing he can do about that one lurking back shot
in tight save made to delovic rebound score Jason
Robertson how many times have we seen Robertson
just outweight a leg or an arm or a Defender gets
his own rebound the first shot is blocked by ludig
and then follows it up and shovels a backhand
through n delovic David sard would be welcome in
this off game score right off the draw TI to Foley
second of the game Power Play goal as the former
Montreal Canadian giving headaches to his former
Squad how you retrieve that puck how are you
hungry are you going a battle and look at that
little Nifty play along the wall from who else
Jack Hughes Saturday night here's ptra and aoad
he scores what a great move by ptra he sniffed
out the loose Puck finds the space in the middle
of the IIs this is really strong work by ptra to
stay with Cory Perry and then he takes it to his
forehand around the left pad of Peter morazzi
behind for the first time Mar that brought eron
scores this is a great movie eventure by Eric
who kind of gets lost in behind everybody kind
of moves out of the front of the net Evon gets
Puck watch in here on this play he eventually
comes right down low to him just a little too
hard of a shift up gives him that Split Second
to walk into the net left all alone and a great
finish by him backhand to forehand elevation in
[Music] tight [Music] a